all right greg question for you i'm
gonna use a little bit of uh
creative license here to uh to rephrase
it
so uh mika asked fiber type
differentiation
as consequence of us a specific stimulus
i'm thinking the question there is can
you intentionally train for a shift in
fiber type is that how how you interpret
that
yeah yeah i i think that's uh i think
that's what mika is asking
so um yes you can
and it's
well you you can to some extent um
so this question
or the this answer catches a lot of
people off guard
um and probably
less so now since andy galpin is pretty
well known at this point
but if you um
if you took an anatomy and physiology
class
at any point during the last 20 years
you probably learned that fiber type
inner conversion
between type 2a and type 2x fibers
is possible and happens all the time but
you probably also learned
that fiber type inner conversion between
type 1 and type 2 fibers
doesn't really happen um or if it does
happen it's only under
very extreme circumstances so for
example
with aging type 2 motor nerves can die
and then offshoots of type 1 motor
nerves can re-innervate
those prior type 2 fibers and then they
become type 1 fibers but
that's kind of um a somewhat
extreme case so but but you you probably
learned that just from normal
day-to-day exercise training you don't
get inner conversion of type 1 and type
2 fibers
so what we
now know is that
we thought that mainly due to pretty
crude methods
of identifying fibers um so
it would primarily just be taking a
muscle biopsy
cutting it uh cutting a cross section of
it staining it
and then based on how dark or how light
those stained fibers showed up as
just identifying them as type 1 type 2a
or type 2x fibers and putting them
neatly into those three categories
there is a much more time consuming but
a much
better method of quantifying fiber types
where you you basically take
single fibers and use gel
electrophoresis
to be able to quantify the percentage of
different myosin heads within that
muscle fiber
um and then you do that for a slew of
fibers and that gives you
a better idea of of the spectrum of
fiber types an individual has
and that gives us the insight that there
are hybrid fiber types
so you have some fibers that
all of the myosin heads are type 1
you have some fibers where all of the
myosin heads are
are type 2 a and
most people don't have true type 2x
fibers where
all of the myosin heads within the fiber
are type 2x
but some people have a smattering of
them
but then especially for untrained
athletes
you have a lot of hybrid fibers where
you know maybe in one fiber
seventy percent of the myosin heads are
type two a thirty percent are
uh type one and another fiber maybe it's
seventy percent type one
thirty percent type 2a uh or a hybrid
between
2a and 2x where you know some of the
myosin heads are
2a myosin some of them are 2x and then
you can either even have hybrids that
have type 1 myosin heads type 2a
and type 2x so
hybrid fibers are a thing and
there is um so one of the hallmarks of
training
is that you basically lose hybrid fibers
um and you lose them in the direction
that you train for the most part
so you know let's say you have
just to make let's just assume type 2x
fibers don't exist for a second just to
make this illustration easy
let's say pre-training you have 40
pure type 1 fibers 40 pure type 2a
fibers
and 20 percent type 1 type 2a hybrid
fibers
if you do aerobic training
then those hybrid fibers will shift and
become
pure type 1 fibers such that after a
fair amount
of training it would look something
pretty close to 60
type 1 40 type 2a with very very few
hybrid fibers
if you d trained again it would probably
go back to 40 40 20
type 1 type 2a and hybrid if
instead you did resistance training or
some sort of anaerobic training
um like like heavy anaerobic training so
like weightlifting strong man
probably throwing stuff like that
it would shift the other directions such
that you would wind up with 40
type 1 60 type 2a and very very few
hybrids
so having a lot of hybrid fibers is
uh kind of a hallmark of being a very
low training status
um and just being pretty sedentary for
the most part
and trained athletes so i don't know
i i don't know and i don't even know how
you would study
whether like a pure type 2a fiber
could become a pure type 1 fiber i
i don't even know how you would quantify
that but what we do know is you can get
very substantial fiber type
differentiation within those hybrid
fibers
based on how you train
and another thing is if you do have any
type 2x fibers
they pretty much just go away with
training
um i remember
learning in x-fiz that doing
power training would cause a fiber type
inner conversion from type 2a to type 2x
um my professor that taught me that
wasn't really a muscle fizz guy so
i don't know that he was basing that on
any evidence i think
he may have just assumed that that's how
it works so that's how he taught us but
if you learn something similar that
doesn't really happen
um there there is some research that if
you do
pretty low volume power training you can
better preserve type 2x myosin heads
within your muscle fibers but i don't
necessarily know that that's a
beneficial thing but yeah for the most
part
your proportion of type 2x myosin heads
goes
down with training regardless of what
type of training you do
and those hybrids get interconverted
or get converted primarily to either
pure type 1
or pure type 2a in the direction of the
type of training you do
so if you do resistance training you'll
mostly get conversion of hybrid fiber
types to type 2a fibers
if you mostly do aerobic endurance
training
you'll mostly get conversion of those
hybrid fibers to type 1 fibers
i have a follow-up question sure so if
this
conversion can occur due to training do
you think
it matters do you think it's something
that we ought to intentionally train for
or do you see it as a consequence of
training
um yeah i see it as a consequence of
training i mean
so you wouldn't tell somebody to go out
and say you should train like this so
that you convert these
fibers no i i mean
the direction of the fiber type
conversions
kind of makes sense like yeah if you
if you want to be an endurance athlete
you probably want
more type 1 myosin heads within within
your muscle fibers
and so just doing endurance training
will give you that adaptation and you
don't
specifically have to do a specialized
form of endurance
training to cause that adaptation and
same would apply for
type 2a myosin heads and resistance
training
so yeah i i don't i don't
i i can't think of a situation where you
would need to train for that
adaptation that would be outside of the
normal training
you would want to do for whatever
other types of adaptations you're aiming
for yeah
can i take a moment to brag really quick
yeah you mentioned uh
learning undergrad x fizz muscle
physiology did i ever tell you about
who i learned muscle physiology from no
so
he was the pi on
several studies looking at myostatin
inhibition
um starting with rodent models then
working up to primate models
and at the time that i was in that class
which was about 10 years ago
he was actually gearing up to do a human
trial on myostatin inhibition
um when he talked about muscle it was
just
so fascinating like i would show up to
that class like 15 minutes early to get
the best seat
it was so cool that's awesome i i never
i never ended up checking in to see
if that human trial got off the ground
or what the results were though
i need to check that out someday